The Sasquatch is a zip line built in 2015 that connects Whistler...
...and Blackcomb mountains in British Columbia, Canada.
This 1.36-mile or 2.2-kilometer zip line...
...will be an experience like no other.
The Sasquatch starts high up on Blackcomb mountain...
...at an elevation of almost 5,000 feet or 1,500 meters...
...and drops steeply along the slope of Blackcomb mountain...
...before leaving the tree line,...
...crossing the valley and coasting to the other side.
Hairpin turns with steep drops go on for ten minutes...
...before you reach the start of the Sasquatch.
After the initial drop of the zip line,...
...it rounds out, launching you between the two mountains.
The moment the line decreases its slope and the tree line ends,...
...you'll be hit with a massive gust of wind, spinning you wildly.
As you coast downward towards Whistler mountain,...
...speeds will continue to increase until about the halfway point.
Top speeds of 87 to 93 miles per hour or 140 to 150 kilometers per hour...
...have been recorded.
Depending on your speed, the Sasquatch will last...
...around a minute and a half of constant zipping.
This is as close as it gets to the feeling of flying like a bird...
...while still connected to the ground.